what have you seen just believing in
somebody due to their confidence
[Music]
um
it uplifts them and it motivates them
the Bible clearly says there's life and
depth in the power of the tongue and I
use the tongue to uplift you I mean when
I say girl girl girl
you see what I'm saying like like that's
automatic and it's the same thing when a
woman looks at a man say you go boy boy
you boy you did that but you did that I
mean and when I'm telling my kids uh we
had instance on the sideline
um this last game but Jimmy was having a
horrific game he's a receiver Jimmy horn
and I said Jimmy you're a dog
we from Florida man and guess what pop
is at the crib and he's incarcerated
watching you right now
and he wants to clap in front of all his
different inmates Because he believes in
his son we gonna make pumpkin proud
tonight that's what we gonna do because
his son is a dog now you go out there
and show the world who you are
and in return he went and caught the
touchdown the game tying touchdown and
he was having her written this night but
just speaking life into Jimmy and
understand where he was right here where
he was located I've been there because I
sympathize and empathize with him and I
know his background and his situation so
I'm able to pull that intangible out of
him that I connect to him in a pivotal
time like that and that's why I got to
know my I got to know my kids
I got to know this team I got to know
them individually as well as
collectively